and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Captain America
oh mighty jazzy the greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
I pledge allegiance to spoilers Piercy
sky called mr. Rogers oh my god mr.
Rogers in this movie won't to be my
Avenger only he's very very tiny hey you
know that stick figure on the cover of
Diary of a Wimpy Kid
he looks pregnant compared to him and he
does what any little shrimp wants to do
join the army I joined the army once you
know the policy Don't Ask Don't Tell but
well they said I was the first case of
Don't Ask Don't Ask Don't Ask so even
though he tries to join the army if they
can no perfidy because his head is three
times the size of his body seriously he
looks like someone put a Barbie head on
a GI Joe
but then the scientist comes and says he
needs him for an experiment I'm looking
for a little shrimp to experiment on
okey where do I fit in
actually every word in that sentence
relates to you I don't follow just get a
net dangerous-looking machine okay
totally blast him with all these
theorems and sciency stuff to write to
me
but there are evil traitors in their
myths congratulations here's a bomb oh
my god he did the psych that other movie
terms of endearment don't even though
the scientist is dead mr. Rogers becomes
really popular in the media people are
like we're gonna turn you into the
manliest person unearthed by giving you
the gayest costume possible this is the
40s do we even know case exists yet hey
we're in the media if we don't put a
Kimber on it it's not real great so they
decide to call Captain America and dress
him like Wonder Woman's bowling ball but
Captain America is like I thought I
would have more dignity than this did
you even read the comic no but I watch
my breath but thankfully he has two
people to help him feel better
a smoking out woman maybe secretary may
be general bombshell with a fake job
description and Tommy Lee Jones on Tommy
Lee Jones I was here to play Tommy Lee
Jones I'm Tommy Lee Jones it's not
enough to be Captain America feel
America is he chose an enemy territory
to break out some prisoners that's right
he could have released nice into the
camp in the mill tonight with a giant
shield with red white and blue on it
probably show called him captain
bullseye but he brings him out of prison
and suddenly he's a real hero
this calls for upgrades my classroom
even sillier than it was before
I want my head to look like a flying
metal blueberry and my shield can look
more like a bull's-eye maybe Wow
white center in the middle I'll be
easier to sneak in that point Sarge at
an NRA convention by the way if you're
watching Boy George don't try that but
it turns out there's an evil bad guy
who's watching him
his name is Red Skull why I don't know I
went to the bathroom when they explained
that as he has a gun that can turn
anybody into radioactive toilet scum
I was radioactive Titus come once there
wiii be peace to them so captain america
flies into a plane to stop the Red Skull
because Red Skull gives you wings sorry
and then evil Red Skull is like no never
give up Doyle Captain America is like
nope okay don't defeat the evil red
scarlet but fight he has to crash the
plane in the Antarctic in order to save
the world
I didn't never do that so he crashes
something into the snow and gets frozen
for several years
hey know him and Christopher Lloyd have
something in common I'll give you a
minute for that to sink in okay it's all
eventually he's thought down by samuel
l.jackson dressed as a pirate yo mother
came home i captain america is like what
do you want with me I have a mission for
you
no God is this another cheap trailer for
The Avengers movie no it's not a cheap
trailer oh it's an actual train oh
that's right we finally get a trailer
for The Avengers movie or is I need to
call it it's turning because we don't
have any of the action scene shot yet
great so Captain America was a really
really good movie there was only one
thing missing though where's my American
movie about my favorite planet Eire oh
yeah he died and may or may not be
coming back
I guess these movies really doing
something in common they're all parties
says they she just called every movie
that comes out now taut cheese the movie
wait didn't I see that behind a beaded
curtain
this is jittery boom sing
I'll help my team be in the Avengers
movie or at the very least attorneys
mustache